well this is what we know so far about
who's been arrested most members of
sudan's civilian leadership including
members of the transitional sovereignty
council have been detained by the
military as we mentioned earlier prime
minister abdullah has been taken to an
unknown location according to the
culture and information ministry his
media adviser faisal muhammad salla has
been detained so has mohammed al-fakhi
suleiman he's the spokesman for the
sovereign council and has been vocally
criticizing the military and the
ministry the minister of industry
ibrahim al-shaikh and the minister of
information hamza balul have also been
placed under arrest according to reports
let's go live then to sudan's capital
khartoum al jazeera's heber morgan is uh
on the line now heber morgan uh
we're going to interrupt you in a moment
because we're expecting a statement
in fact we're going to that statement
right now let's listen
who doesn't believe in peace and justice
that's why when the december
revolutionaries
say their slogans and thousands of them
stood in front of the general command of
the armed forces the armed forces
responded positively and decided to work
to achieve the aspiration of the people
to achieve the aspiration of the nation
justice
peace and freedom because we are quite
convinced that the sudanese people
deserve
a nation a nation that they can practice
and see
these slogans and these big names in the
nation until the moment we deliver power
to a
civilian government that will achieve
more
during this transitional period
the armed forces were quite aware and
the people
were quite aware
of the partnership between the military
people and the civilians to go through
the same way in order to achieve the
goals of the people through
general elections
through
the practices that we have been
doing and witnessing all over a year
and this will include the leaders and
the powers because other than that
there will be divisions that is that are
a threat to the safety of
our nation
prime minister abdullah
has seen that in his initiative in july
and october
of this year
so the armed forces
because it's the constituent power of
this transitional period
the armed forces has a national duty to
keep and the safety and sovereignty of
the nation according to
the constitutional draft and according
to the mission of the armed forces
that's why we need not
to distract the nation and we need not
to destroy the nation we have started
our path towards the states of freedom
justice and peace but some political
powers are still trying
to maintain everything in their hands
without paying attention to the threats
political threats and economic threats
and social threats
that's why in the armed forces and the
rapid support forces we were keen to
take the necessary steps that will keep
and maintain the december revolution
until we reach the final goal which is a
civil state via
fair and just elections that's why we
decided the following to declare a state
of emergency
nationwide
to adhere and to commit ourselves to
what has been mentioned in the
constitutional document
and the agreement of peace in sudan
signed in juba in october 2020
three
do we suspend
the oppression of article 11
12
15 and 16
23 24 3 71 72
of the constitutional
uh
draft
and we commit ourselves to all the
agreement signed by
us
we
dissolve the sovereign council
and the cabinet
and
we
put an end to the job of the mayors
and the under secretaries
and the
the
department
and the general department in the states
will
do their job and we will revise
everything
and we will take
decisions towards everything
and we urge everyone to abide by
the agreement of juba 2020 we stress
and we confirm
that some
of our people in the east
have their own
sufferings and we are quite sure
that justice and peace must prevail
so we need to work hard in order to
reach
last solutions
that will meet the aspirations of our
people and that would sort out the
problems nationwide we believe that the
december revolution is going on because
the people who have started this
revolution
believe in the golden aims and goals of
the revolution
and we
all
starting from today
till the date of the elections in july
2023
we urge everyone to work hard
to pave the way for better living to
create a better environment for the
parties to work hard until the date of
the elections we need everyone to be
ready to lead the country after the
elections
a government of independent people will
be formed after elections to represent
all the people of the sudan we will be
keen
to apply every rule of justice
and we will support
the judiciary the constitutional court
the
uh
all the
cornerstones that will help our nation
to
be solid and strong
uh revolutionary parliament will be also
created to monitor the situation
and to monitor the steps being taken for
the welfare of the sudanese people we
need to work hard we need to produce
because our people and our nation
deserves all sacrifices we need to keep
our country and we need to keep our
people safe we are quite committed to
the items of the
constitutional agreement and the juba
agreement and we urge abdullah aziz
we urge abdullah muhammad
to join the path of building the new
sedan
sudan where freedom justice will prepare
because
no group or no individual will impose
their opinion again
on sudanese people we thank iran and we
thank the friends of sudan because their
ongoing support in order to make this
transition period a success a big salute
to our great people of sudan for the
sake of the country and for the sake of
the nation
i would like to thank
members
of the armed forces and the rapid
support forces who are doing the best
may allah bestow his mercy on our
martyrs
and allah almighty will do
what allah almighty wants and peace be
upon you all all right that was uh abdel
fattah
council chairman speaking on sudanese tv